je vais donc rejoindre le père noël du
marron d'éguzon bonjour jacky bonjour
mais c'est la foire d'empoigné tout à
fait comment ça se fait qu'ils aient
autant de gens qui attendent alors
explique alors aux échos
c'est à dire ils n'ont pas respecté les
consignes à savoir prise de rendez-vous
parce qu'il faut prendre rendez vous
pourriez plus tard tout à fait pour
avoir une fluidité de du travail et
disons que les gens soient satisfaits
alors c'est fait avec une machine très
particulière qui a derrière vous voilà
jacky cette machine c'est un prototype
au départ voilà c'était un prototype qui
est ici depuis plus d'une vingtaine
d'années et donc qui nous permet de
du produit brut de la châtaigne de là à
sortir ensuite sensé 2 po et le récent
épluché ça veut dire qu'il n'a pas
d'autre ailleurs des machines comme
celle l'heure actuelle y en a en
fabrication il y en a en vente ailleurs
d'ailleurs par des gens qui sont venus
nous voir l'année dernière qui nous ont
fait travailler mais bon on les
adhérents les adorent ils sont ce sont
des bretons on travaille sont avec nous
ici aujourd'hui donc pour bien
comprendre quand on a ramassé quand on
veut les éplucher il faut prendre rendez
vous avec vous voilà donc vous épluchez
parce que vous travaillez à l'épluchage
des châtaignes bien avant la fête alors
on travaille grosso modo deux semaines
avant
j'ai combien à l'îlot de tonnes alors
l'année dernière
nous sommes arrivés à pratiquement
quatre tonnes de quatre tonnes de
châtaignes épluché bon c'est colossal
j'ai pas sur les a tous mon genre cette
année cette année cent parce qu'on a
donc les gens qui ont investi dans du
matériel ne sont donc pas revenu nous
voir et donc on a
une diminution dillon un apport moindre
de 700 à 800 kilos qui est compensée par
des particuliers mais cependant voilà
les gens viennent font peser et paya
ensuite en fonction du poids racontez
nous comment ça se passe pour cette
machine ouest tomber les châtaignes
d'abord alors donc la première chose
dont on fait la poser
ensuite la châtaigne enfin les
châtaignes son bis dans une trémie très
près mais avec une chaîne élévatrices
donc elle grimpe ici voilà qu'on va
régler le débit de la chaîne élévatrices
et on suit ça va tout doucement en fait
ouais parce qu on règle un débit on peut
l'augmenter mais c'est ensuite le bon ça
pose des problèmes et une fois qu'elle
arrive on ou alors une fois qu'elle
arrive en haut et elles vont tomber dans
un dans un four
qui est là et l'on travaille à peu près
entre 600 à 800 degrés ça tel four qui
tourne voilà le four tourner et les
châtaignes circulent dedans mais j'ai
dit combien de temps vous garantir c'est
très très très peu plus c'est à dire on
est entre disons
l'amusante rémy et lorsqu'on est en flux
continu la mise en premier la sortie on
est à
minimum à kg minutes donc une fois
qu'elles sont passées dans le four elle
arrive dans ce gros tonneau l'acquis et
pearl est alors ce cotonou là c est
composé de deux pièces une pièce fixe un
stator est une sorte de grosse de grille
avec des mailles de
10 mm à peu près et c'est ce qui permet
en fait d'avoir les épluchures python à
l'intérieur et derrière juste qu'on
comprenne derrière les châtaignes qui
sont épluchés là elles sont finis avec
les petits couteaux voilà voilà parce
que quand on skie pour bien savoir c'est
que pendant la châtaigne pour la
châtaigne greffé il ya quand même ce
qu'on appelle des déguisements
l'intérieur de de la châtaigne alors que
le marron il n'en a pas on est bien là
son chat gris et c'est une différence
primordial exactement et on est bien
d'accord vous êtes le personnage
incontournable
donc s'il venait à éguzon ce qu'il faut
faire c'est venir voir ja qui pourrait
pêcher au maroc on se retrouve tout à
l'heure sur la photo de famille sur
rendez vous je compte sur vous à tout à
l'heure à qui merci